Hi everyone, my name is Brian Buckland
and I'm from IBM Cloud.
Today we're going to be talking about multi-tenancy.
Multi-tenancy in the cloud means using shared services and resources for multiple clients.
These resources can include:
compute,
networking,
and storage.
Each tenant's data is isolated
and is invisible to other tenants.
You might ask why I have an apartment building here.
The apartment building provides a good example of what a multi-tenancy is.
Each tenant has their own key.
Each tenant can come and go into their apartment as they please,
and they can add and remove items to their apartment
as long as they're following the building guidelines and regulations.
So, all the tenants of the building can access the building,
but they can only access their own apartment.
So, therefore, all the other apartments are secure because you can only access your own.
A tenant may invite somebody from the outside world to their apartment
as an authorized person
but by default each apartment is
secured and locked down.
So, the building:
the building is providing us with shared resources.
These shared resources can include
for an example, water
and electricity.
These shared resources are available to the whole building,
and as a tenant of this building we can choose
how much, or how little, of these shared resources we wish to use.
The apartment building will meter your usage of these resources
and there we have a multi-tenancy using our shared resources.
This is a good example and relationship to what we have over here in the cloud environment.
Each tenant can have as small, or as big, allocations of compute, network, and storage.
It is really up to the end-user how big or how small they want their environment to be.
To summarize, just some of the benefits to multi-tenancy include:
scalability,
we can also have lower entry cost.
So, lower entry costs is, you know, you can start small and you can grow.
The last one I put up there, let me write this one out, is cloud maintains ...
... maintains these shared resources.
So, they will manage to compute, the network, and the storage,
and make sure there's always ample available for you to utilize.
Thank you for watching this video.
If you have any questions or comments, please drop us a line below.
Want to see more videos like this in the future? Be sure to LIKE and subscribe.
Please do not forget you can always get started in the cloud at no cost by signing up for a free IBM Cloud account.